la saison de la construction est lancée
et s'annonce bien remplie pour cette
entreprise qui construit ici des
immeubles de six logements et défis sont
le son regret on a c'est de venir à bout
de ressources
j'ai des humains pierre tables d'environ
2 moore et on a douté un mois tout
dépendant
alors que la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
ralentit déjà la cadence sur des
chantiers s'ajoutent les difficultés
d'obtenir certains matériaux comme les
portes les fenêtres l'ipo tel et les
fermes de toit à 20 fermes de toit on
parlait d'environ trois semaines à un
mois maximum aujourd'hui pour placer une
commande qui sont place in common law
présentement on a surfé en avant
les usines n'arrive pas à répondre à la
demande encore une fois le manque de
personnel est en cause ce manque de main
d'oeuvre vient réduire la quantité de
matériaux qui sont disponibles qui
sortent des manufactures ou qui sortent
des importations un effet de rareté qui
fait grimper les briques et la hausse
des cours du pétrole n'aide pas les
choses que ce soit des cols des
lubrifiants des peintures l'ensemble des
matières plastiques on retrouve dans
l'industrie quant aux déportés fnac
n'est pas seulement là dedans ça va
contenir du pétrole
conséquence le prix des maisons neuves a
explosé en deux ans dont on est dos à
18% par rapport à la même période
l'année dernière depuis le début de la
pandémie on était en étant de 30 et 35
pour ça
pour se protéger de la hausse des coûts
des matériaux stéphane latour conclu des
ententes qui contiennent un mécanisme
d'ajustement des prix
les clients qui ont signé leur contrat
il ya un an voient donc leur facture
grimper américain spéciale en
augmentation sur le bâtiment total on
suit le marché puisse aider casse place
toutes les factures journal appuie plus
notre pourcentage afin que le
consommateur sache au moment où il signe
son contrat
ce à quoi il s'engage
les clients doivent être vigilants dit
l'association des consommateurs pour la
qualité dans la construction
on a vu des coptes ont par exemple un
entrepreneur contre et deux maisons
pareil une à côté de l'autre et les deux
clients ont pas la même hausse de prix
près de soixante huit mille mises en
chantier ont été effectués dans le
secteur résidentiel l'an dernier au
québec un niveau inégalé depuis plus de
30 ans ce nombre devrait baisser à 55
milles cette année selon la pch que le
bassin d'acheteurs rétréci en raison de
la hausse des prix
ici olivier bachand radio canada koans
ville